BETTER THAN THE FEDERAL
GENTLEMAN.
I THINK IT IS A GOOD THING.
>> THANK YOU, THANKS, SHERIFF,
I HAVE ONE MORE ISSUE BEFORE WE
SAY GOODBYE.
INCIDENT WITH YOU AND A
PASSENGER ON A FLIGHT TO
MILWAUKEE A YEAR AGO.
THE SENTINAL WANT REPORTING THE
FBI GOT INVOLVED.
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
WHILE THERE ARE NO CHARGES THE
I WOULD LIKE TO GET YOUR TAKE ON
THAT.
>> IT IS A FRIVOLOUS LAWSUIT.
I CAN'T SAY MUCH THIS IS A FAKE
NEWS STORY.
I KNOW HOW PRESIDENT TRUMP FEELS
TO BE IN THE CENTER OF FAKE NEWS
I SENT YOU THE LETTER.
THEY FOUND NO WRONG DOING.
THE CASE IS CLOSED.
HERE WE ARE IN DECEMBER THEY ARE
TRYING TO REDIG THIS STORY WITH
LIES
LIE
LIES INTERWOVEN TO MAKE IS TEAM
NEW.
THERE WAS NO WRONG DOINGIS I WAS
DOING GOOD POLICE WORK AND THE
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE RESCUE MYSELFD
>> SHERIFF.
-- SHOULD HAVE.